ええ、みんなはーヤンヤンつけボーというお菓子知っているだろうか？
スーパーとかコンビニとかで、よく見ると思うんだが、
皆さん食べたことはありますでしょうか？こちらです
結構どこでも見ると思うんですけども
ヤンヤンつけボーどのようなお菓子かっていうと 、ふつうにこうやって開けます
開けると３か所に区分されております。
で、どうやって食べるかといいますと
こうやって棒取ってチョコにこうやってつけて
パウダーちょんちょんてつけて
食べると
(ﾎﾟｷｯ）うまい☆
でも、
ヤンヤンつけボーはおいしいんですけどぉ
棒をちまちまとチョコレートにつけ、
パウダーにつけてパクパクやってると
なんか、
おいしい・・・です本当に美味しいんですけど
めんどくせぇのと、こまこましててものたりない
って思う人多いと思うんですよ。やっぱり
そんなちょ～っと物足りない＼(^o^)／ヤンヤンつけボーのために今回！
ガァン!!!!
この世に一つしかない、、、、この世にこの世に一つしかない!!!
～＼(^o^)／と思うぜｳｪｯﾍｯﾍｯﾍｩwww
いや本当に多いと思うんですよ。
ヤンヤンつけボー
小さくてものたりない
そんなことを思った＼(^o^)／私、
サイズ比較こんなものですね
これぐらいのスケールでヤンヤンつけボー作ったら
最高に
と思いまして
でけーヤンヤンつけボー食ったらその細々しさがなくなるんじゃないかと思いまして
早速つくっていこうと思います
ではいこう☆
というわけで早速作っていこうと思います
まずはチョコベースになるチョコを作っていきたいと思うんですけど
なかなか棒を刺してとぅるって取れる柔らかいチョコを作るのは難しいということで
あの僕、すごい平気な顔をしてるんですけど
実はこの部屋
ありがとうございますww
こんな顔してますが実は
助けて下さい　助けて下さい
という訳でこんな暑い中だと
板チョコを入れていい感じに解けるんじゃないかと
まずはかたっぱしから板チョコを入れていきたいと思います
ダイジェストォォォォ
おし、入れ終わりました
ちょっと部屋の温度だけではなかなかチョコが溶けないので
スチャ☆
いや暑いぞこれ
早送り
はい、という訳で、だいぶ溶けてきました
これ実際バケツと比べて少なく見えると思うんですけど
実はヤンヤンつけボーのチョコって
結構カップに対して少ないんですよ
カップのここらへんしかチョコないんで
結構いい割合だと思います
はいでは続いてパウダーの方作っていきましょう
この入っている部分がなんか三角コーナーっぽいんで
実際の三角コーナーを使っていきます
できました☆
で、ここに
パウダーをたくさん入れていきます
結構たくさん！！入ったと！！！思います！！！！
あぁ！！！！！！！
はい！！！！！（。∀ ﾟ）
というわけで無事
ねっく？（発音が悪くてわからない）ポイントもありますが、気にせず見ていきましょう
チョコがここにたまってるんですけど
棒を入れてすくってパウダーをちょんっとつけて、ぱくぅって食べる感じです
ただ、チョコがちょっと硬いんで
食べる際は、
このドライヤーをつけてぇ!!!!（大声）
チョコを溶かしてぇ!!!!（大声）
食べてくれるとぉ!!!（大声）
とても食べやすいと思います！！（また頭が狂った）
ちょ、うるさい、一回静かにしといて
ヤンヤンつけボーの代わりを探した時に、なかなか見つからなくて
もぉ！！！
これしかないとおもって、フランスパンを準備しました
おぉ、、いいサイズだ
お、ピッｔ…
さぁ、こんなこともあろうかと、たくさんフランスパンを準備しておいた
ハッハッハァ！！！
これでくぁｗせｄｒｆｔｇｙふじこｌｐ!!!
ハアアアァァ！！！ヴォオオオ！！！（発狂）
というわけで、早速食べてみましょう
大事なのは、、、
味です（ｷﾘｯ
あ、でも全然つく
すげぇぇ、全然つきます。。
これをここにたくさんパウダーをつけると
（きらん✨）
完全にヤンヤンつけボーだ
早速食べてみようと思います
これが、世界一大きい…
（きあいだめ）
ﾔﾝヤンつけボーだ！！！（キレ気味）
いたただきます。。（さっきのはなんだったんだろ。。）
ふぅ（鼻笑）
いただきます
うっふっふっふぅぅう
つでつでつでつでつで
たーたららららーらーらーらーらーらーらららららーらーらーらーらーらーらららららららららっ
ははははっ
ヤンヤンつけボーの棒固いから、たぶん、フランスパンにして正解なんだよね
あとおぉ！！！
とても一人では…食べれません（ら抜き言葉）
だれかぁぁぁぁーーーーーーーー